i love huntress i love the version of
her that that we got to make and um you
know if that version of her continues i
would be more than happy to to keep her
going who are you
i'm kate
mary i understand that you had the same
scent coordinator from birds of prey on
kate was that like an easier transition
from you what was the most challenging
part from going from huntress into kate
that that was an amazing thing about
this film was that i had that training
background with him already so he
already knew what i could do what i was
capable of how far he could push it you
know what direction to kind of take the
choreography and that would kind of suit
my abilities the best so i think that's
really a large part of what made me able
to do almost everything in this film was
that jojo kind of knew me and knew how
to work towards those strengths and i'm
so grateful for it because i love
getting to train with those guys and
getting to feel like i'm right in the
middle of it and i'm really doing it
with them um it's just like the best
feeling at the end of the day crossbow
or pistol or sniper rifle like what is
your weapon of choice now oh god you
know i
loved the scene in kate um where we're
fighting in a kitchen and i'm using like
wine glasses and a coffee grinder and
just whatever is at my disposal i think
that's the most fun it's just like being
resourceful and just turning random
items into a weapon is it's very
exciting hey nice what the hell is up
with this bow and arrow it's not a bow
and arrow it's a crossbow i'm not 12. i
love this chick she's got rages i don't
have rage issues we know that there is
going to be a black hilarious spin-off
would you be interested in a huntress
spin-off movie oh for sure i love
huntress i love the version of her that
that we got to make and um you know if
that version of her continues i would be
more than happy to to keep her going but
we'll see we'll see what happens who
knows
need a ride
kate was like an anxiety-filled
adrenaline ride the entire time mary
what was it like playing this badass
woman drenched in fake blood and how
difficult was it for you to wash off
kate both literally and figuratively at
the end of each night that's true you
know you're sort of bringing back
flashbacks of how much showering i had
to do at the end of every day it was a
lot because there was a lot of blood but
also as the film progresses you know
she's dying
of radiation poisoning and she's getting
shot
beat up you know so i had a build up of
prosthetics and wounds and different
things so it was washing off blood but
also finding like fake bits of skin
everywhere like prosthetics constantly
that would just not come off all the
so sometimes i would forget and we were
shooting in thailand um oftentimes like
in big malls and things and i'd have to
come in and out of these very public
spaces and i would forget what i looked
like and people were always looking at
me very strange i would be like hi i
don't know why i'm gonna say i was like
did you ever really have to pop into a
convenience store and totally forget
that you have an open wound yeah i
always forgot and i you know i'd
remember wow yeah that's why i'm getting
this strange
the things we do to bring an assassin to
life exactly yes oh they're scary
well miku while mary had to deal with
all the blood you had the braces what
was it like for the return on that
i people think they were fake
and they didn't just put it on for the
roll but they were my actual braces i
had them on for like two years and when
i booked the roll i was like so do i get
my braces off like are we gonna put them
off and they're like no we're gonna keep
them it adds to the character at first i
was like okay
but like i've grown to really like it on
ani so yeah
okay you're like that person and a
nightmare take out no dudes
but miku it's just so cool because this
is really like your big film debut and
you got to share all of your scenes with
the amazing mary how
cool was that for you and did you
fangirl with her over any of her past
roles
yeah of course all my friends have
knew you i never even talked to you
about this
from scott pilgrim my best friend she
was obsessed with you and i was like
yeah and you were so sweet when i first
met you
and you're just great to work with so
you're very sweet just doing scenes with
her and just watching how she does these
little things it's funny because in the
movie annie really looks up to kate and
she's like learning how to be a badass
from her and in real life i feel like i
was like learning so much from you as a
person which is a total killer babe
thanks one thing that i was surprised to
know is that the two of you ladies play
ukulele
and then you would like serenade the
crew on set was that your way to keep it
light what was how did you guys even
figure this out
well i think i just saw you bringing
ukulele to set one day and i was like oh
my goodness like i i play the ukulele
too so i brought mine to set and then we
just started playing and it was it was
really nice because the scenes were so
chaotic and so
and it turned out the director played
ukulele as well cedric so it was like we
were like and uh
are we about to have a girl group like
sort of folk tunes
girl group i know we were very we sang
all very soft warm and fuzzy songs it
was like a real contrast to what was
going on on set first
how much time do we have
not much
mary we've seen like i said these two
kick-ass ladies from you what's next for
you what are you excited to focus on i
don't really know i i would love to keep
the action thing going i have so much
fun with it um i especially love finding
projects like like kate um and huntress
where you really feel like there's an
interesting character you know deep down
inside to bring out you know amongst all
the action and the gore and feeling like
the physicality is just an extension of
who they are um and getting to bring
that out is is really fun and i hope to
continue to find those kind of roles we
are in the age of reboots and reunions
if you could revisit a pass role now who
would you choose oh my gosh um
i you know i got to do like a 10-year
read-through of this film
pilgrim versus the world i'm like you
don't need to say this film we all know
it's so funny because it's just been
over the past 10 years it's really grown
in popularity and so it's it's so nice
to see that people still like it and are
still discovering it and i think it
would be really cool to see where those
characters are you know 10 15 years
later um it would be it would be a nice
one to revisit
you want to come with me
[Music]
you